here with reaction to all of this and
tonight's top stories Fox and Friends
Weekend co-host Pete Heth Fox News
contributor Jason chaitz and Fox News
legal analyst Greg Jared Jason let me
start with you what so what I think is
going on behind the scenes here is we
know that contempt charges were brought
in the case of Steve Bannon and in the
case of Peter Navaro uh we know that Jim
Jordan's Judiciary Committee is
investigating whether or not the doj and
the FBI have been weaponized and politic
ized so if they charge Navaro and they
charge Bannon but they don't charge
Hunter Biden uh doesn't that put meric
Garland doesn't that basically prove the
point in the investigation of Judiciary
in terms of a two-tier justice system
and and politics and and how and
weaponization yeah it really would drive
home the point uh look I I used to be
the chairman of that committee I could
unilaterally issue subpoenas mostly you
would have a convers ation with somebody
and say do you want me to issue this
subpoena it's stroking my pen I'll be
done with this in the next two seconds
or you can appear now the reality is
Hunter Biden doesn't need a subpoena to
appear if he's if he really wants to get
in there and talk to him he just needs
to tell him the date and show up but if
he's not going to do that yeah issue is
subpoena I think uh Jim Jordan chairman
Jordan chairman comr are doing a
fabulous job of this should continue
they should move forward in the house
they should go forward with contempt
this Punk called Hunter Biden has LED
his whole 53 years of his life on his
daddy's coattails and America's sick of
it and he has never learned the lesson
that he needs to actually comply with
things and do things I mean look at the
the abandonment of of his own own child
there and what they went through there
so don't give us these lectures about
you know from Jill Biden Dr Jill Biden
talking about how the house is picking
on him just abide by the rules and
you'll be fine no she claimed that
they're being cruel if you want to talk
about cruelty I think he hit the nail on
the head when you mentioned it's cruel
that Joe and Jill Biden didn't recognize
their own granddaughter for over four
years and were only shamed into it by
Morin doubt at the New York Times uh and
shows like this uh Greg let me talk to
you about from a legal standpoint may
maybe clever on Abby Low's part to say
issue a new subpoena here are my
suggestions for the new subpoena uh but
they don't need a new subpoena
um I've got to imagine the odds of
probably 6040 he pleads the fifth but if
he does I don't know if that's going to
serve him well in the
end well I agree with you it's a
pretense a charade Hunter Biden is
pretending today through his lawyer oh
gee yeah I'll answer questions now he's
not going to do that he'll take the
fifth he was always going to take the
fifth that's because there's too much
incriminating evidence and he's already
in criminal Jeopardy so if he lies when
confronted with evidence of influence
pedaling and there's mountains of it
he'd be charged with perjury if he tells
the truth he further implicates himself
so I think this was always the plan uh
let's pull these series of stunts we'll
refuse the deposition we'll taunt
Republicans into a public hearing that
Democrats would crater and if it doesn't
work we'll Force the committee uh to
move for contempt so Hunter has pushed
this now to the brink just before the
Wednesday Full House vote on contempt
and the timing reveals the scam today's
offer effectively nullifies pressure on
Joe Biden's doj to prosecute his son for
contempt don't give them the excuse just
issue another subpoena tomorrow and be
done with it and it doesn't matter
because Hunter Biden will not testify
you can see it in his lawyer's letter at
the very end look at it closely he says
he'll comply for a hearing or deposition
he doesn't say he'll testify compliance
is not
testifying well said Pete let me ask you
this I would argue that this never would
have happened except for Jim Jordan the
chairman of Judiciary James comr the
chairman of oversight uh Jason Smith the
chairman of ways and means and the and
the pressure that they have put on and
the light that they have shown about
merri Garland and a two-tier justice
system and the weaponization of the doj
under under Joe Biden and how it's been
politicized just like the FBI because if
they didn't do this to if they did this
to Navaro and Bannon and they don't do
it to
Hunter it's like a SL you you're
reinforcing everything that has been
every charge that has been made against
you do you agree with that I do agree uh
Sean and it's about time it's about time
Republicans Fight Fire with Fire the way
Democrats have Hunter Biden's entire
life his whole all 18 holes are a
mulligan at this point every single part
of what he's been able to get away with
is is a reflection of a corrupt system
that protects its benefactors and then
Republicans want to hand ring over well
we need to provide a proactive positive
policy agenda that voters will connect
fine do all that but in the meantime use
your committees to go after the
corruption in plain sight that people
get away with in the shadowy corners of
Washington which I would never get away
with you would never get away with your
viewers would never get away with and
these committee chairman have shown the
guts to go to the mat and they need to
keep going to the mat on this corruption
all all the way expose it don't worry
about political consequences or side
because they'll they've already done the
same thing to Trump they'll do it to
their opponents and we should Fight Fire
with Fire so I'm glad they're doing it
and what about this idea that that Abby
LOL suggesting that the initial subpena
was legally invalid uh because uh the
Full House of Representatives uh had not
formalized the impeachment inquiry are
you buying that Jason
chaitz absolutely not that is such
hogwash you don't need an impeachment
inquiry to issue a subpoena as I was
chairman we issued all kinds of
subpoenas you don't need that in place
in fact the House of Representatives
under the house rules can issue a subena
to anybody at any time for any reason
there is no pre predicate that says it
has to be you know a an impeachment
inquiry that is such legal hogwash it's
meant to Snicker snooker people nobody's
buying that yeah and then there's this
suggestion I want to get your take on
whether or not it was uh illegally uh it
was legally invalid uh but then lol in a
footnote States and suggested procedure
for a hybrid process of public
deposition Greg that's not how the the
system works I I know they thought it
was a cute talking point when they said
um no we want a public hearing you can
and then comr to his credit said sure
we'll give you a public hearing after we
depose you behind closed doors and we
have the freedom to ask you the
questions that we might not be able to
ask you uh in public uh that's how
that's how that system works but they
want to change the whole system every
step of the way which is it's kind of
the life story of Hunter they didn't
want to charge him the fix was in then
the whistleblowers come out then he gets
a sweetheart deal that fell flat on its
face because of one judge and now here
we are with a very bias special counsel
but Merrick Garland he he's got to he's
got to be thinking about how this all
impacts him
no yeah absolutely and again uh don't
give Garland an excuse not to prosecute
Hunter Biden for contempt just issue a
new
subpoena uh but look a deposition is
vital it's important which is why it's
used because it's not the politicians
who are asking the questions it's the
investigators and lawyers who are
steeped in the knowledge of the case
they know that documents inside and out
they ask penetrating skillful
cross-examination questions you don't
get that in a public hearing where
there's a 5 minute limit and the panel
members you know deliver speeches and
rarely ask a question that's what Hunter
Biden and Abby L want it uh but they
shouldn't get it thank you all hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else